AFIKA NYATI: Hi, my name is
Afika Nyati, and my research
concerns ways in which to
improve the digital reading
experience.
I picked up on and came to
realize through my research
that part of the reason
why many people prefer
to read using print books as
opposed to digital alternatives
has to do with the fact
that many of the useful cues
present in print
books are lost when
you port over the
form and presentation
to digital context.
On top of this, many
people don't actually
find ways in which
to take the added
capabilities of digital
devices to improve the reading
experience over and
above what is possible
using print alternatives.
My research concerned
combining the loss and these
added capabilities
to come up and devise
a new alternative
text presentation that
could aid digital reading.
To inform the design
of this presentation,
I did a bit of
background research
on the visual and
cognitive processes
that happened during
reading, and came
to realize three things--
the first of which,
when we read,
we actually only read
within a specific region
within our visual system
called the FOVIO region.
And because we only can read
in this specific region,
we have to basically scan
the page to parse the words.
And the scanning over time
introduces the cognitive load
associated with trying to
plan for the next gaze.
The second thing is, the
human brain can actually
process about four to
five information units.
What this does is it sets
a constraint on the amount
of words you can actually
process at a specific given
moment.
Lastly, knowing your
place within a document
is very important
in understanding
where you are, which gives you
a sense of the comprehension
and building a
better understanding
of the text as a whole.
So with this
information at hand,
we wanted to design
a presentation that
took that into account, but
also was benchmarked on three
metrics, namely, reading
speed, reading comprehension,
and workload index.
In an ideal world, we
wanted a presentation
that would allow the reader to
read at a rate much faster than
without it, however, not at
the expense of comprehension.
At the same time, we don't
want this presentation
to be a lot harder to
use, which would make it
a lot harder for user adoption.
In a nutshell, what the
presentation does is
it presents a set
fixed number of words
to the reader over
time, however,
at a rate that is dependent
on the words being presented.
To assess the performance
of his presentation,
we benchmarked it against
the standard reading
scroll-based text presentation.
We're currently
running the studies,
so there's no results
at the moment.
But we're optimistic
about the results.